Você teve a edição mínima em suas
mãos pelas últimas 48 horas. Você já viu
o trap score. Já sentiu como é
ter um escudo. Mas enquanto você
observa o score, as baleias já estão
evoluindo. A edição mínima
mostra a porta, mas o protocolo
completo mostra a sala inteira.
Agora mesmo, algoritmos institucionais
estão criando sinais falsos para ativar seu
FOMO. Quando a armadilha fechar, um escudo
mínimo pode não ser suficiente. Você precisa da
suite completa de inteligência visual. Quatro motores
de IA: Grok, GPT, Gemini e
CryptoQuant trabalhando em sincronia. Rastreamento
de baleias em tempo real, filtros de sentimento,
decisões em 3 segundos. Isso não é
apenas trading, é uma vantagem injusta.
Para celebrar nossos novos defensores,
abrimos a campanha do protocolo. Somente para
as próximas 50 pessoas, você pode desbloquear
tudo com 50% de desconto. É proteção
institucional completa por menos de
um dólar por dia. Mas quando as 50 vagas
acabarem, este link expira e o
preço dobra. Não deixe seu capital
na sorte. Atualize seu protocolo
de defesa. Use o código defend50 no checkout
agora mesmo. Bem-vindo à academia completa.
Vamos vencer juntos.